let's move on to the bachelor and
Paradise re-do the sex scandal
investigation is over and some things
fans are very excited the show will live
on
I'm so happy paradise is back
I was kidding this is like our greatest
guilty pleasure of all time like we sit
down a Monday night is like religion in
our house yep action Amelia joined the
six million-plus bachelor nation fans
who are doing a happy dance now the
Paradise is going to start shooting
again cast members have been told the
cameras rolled this weekend at the same
Mexico Resort it's unbelievable this
show it's like the greatest social
experiment of all time
well that social experiment turned into
a two-week internal investigation
conducted by Warner Brothers no evidence
of any wrongdoing or sexual misconduct
was found did you interact with Demario
was he pretty drunk they didn't seem
like they were falling all over the
place they seemed like they were just
drinking
Alex yq-- was another contestant and an
eyewitness in Paradise egl lines lauren
zima spoke with the 27 year old marine
exclusively today I've heard that
Corinne on that second day was covered
in bruises I do remember seeing bruises
and because she was like laughing about
it she like slipped or something it was
it was something completely irrelevant
from the incident with Demario does that
blow your mind that everything that's
happened in a week
I really just went there to hopefully
connect with someone I do want to ask
you to clear up one thing because what
we had seen in one report is that you
and Corinne okay see that I I did I did
hear about that too and I will 100% go
on the record that although I've had a
conversation with Corinne I have never
hooked up with Corinne
so you guys did not kiss we did not kiss
one second we're all filming in the next
second were told the show's over and
that we're getting sent home and through
all of that the amount of the amount of
respect to us and the character that the
producer showed us and they helped us
and they stay in contact with us and the
lawyers I think everyone was just trying
to get to the bottom of it
Warner Brothers and ABC and the show
handled the process was was like sitting
here now in retrospect I really
appreciated it I'm confident in putting
myself back in the position I'm down to
go be a part of the process because I
believe that it was handled the correct
way
[Music]